[Applaudissements]
l'heure est grave de cette chose à part
le conseil de classe de gilles verdez je
vais me poser la semaine dernière la
semaine dernière je faisais 82 kg 4 avec
keanu lundi dernier ce qui est très bien
que j'étais pas c'était pareil ouais
mais là monsieur l'institut et ben
écoutez je peux vous dire que je ne vais
pas vous c'est quoi cette blague j'ai
fait devancé de s'interroger devant la
gare du quesnoy j'essayais c'est quoi
quel est votre dernier repas par exemple
il me dernière pas part au match un
petit sandwich au fromage bamba
montlhéry bouazzara devant l'ordi la
maison il faut qu'ils vous concocte il
prévenu qu'un truc oui il est quoi la
bonne nouvelle c'est quoi
je n'ai passé que j'ai pas pris de
chance de régler et ben là je dois
perdre dans ce cas qu'ils ont d'une
semaine autant dire qu'on est bien là